Петро Порошенко прибирає політичного опонента
Так сприйняли на Заході позбавлення Міхеіла Саакашвілі українського громадянства.
паспорт в Україні стає політичним інструментом, а це не дуже позитивний сигнал для країни, яка пережила Революцію Гідності і прагне до Європи.
Позбавити велику опозиційну фігуру громадянства - звісно, не методи ЄС.
Це нагадує, приміром, ув’язнення Тимошенко та Луценка за часів Януковича.
Це якась неправильна боротьба проти опозиції, що, зрозуміло, є самозахистом.
Але дуже дивно, що чинна влада вирішила таке зробити.
Ця історія, на думку Умланда, може лише зіграти на руку Саакашвілі і допомогти йому здобути нових прихильників.
Адже зараз політика стали підтримувати навіть ті, хто не надто симпатизував йому раніше.
Свого часу Саакашвілі також всіляко намагався позбутися конкурента на виборах - Бідзіни Іванішвілі
і забрав у нього громадянство, нагадують грузинські експерти.
Тиск на опозиціонера тоді згуртував людей, і вибори Саакашвілі зрештою програв.
Однак нині ситуація дещо інша, зазначають грузинські експерти.
Порошенко дав громадянство Міхеілу Саакашвілі для того, щоб він провів відповідні реформи – такі, як свого часу в Грузії.
Але Саакашвілі увесь свій вплив використав на боротьбу з чинним президентом України.
Це протистояння, схоже, триватиме і надалі.
Адже Саакашвілі вже пообіцяв боротися за українське громадянство - і не лише в суді, але і на вулицях.